pour demander ce que ce jour tu
retrouves pas l'épisode 4 de inside
c'est parti on venait de regrouper tous
ces gens sur une plaque qui a finalement
ouvert cette porte et l'autre côté c'est
leur dette une sorte de guerre c'est
parti qu'il y at-il donc de l'autre côté
de cette porte
c'est d'accord donc c'est bien la guerre
on part belle est bien sûr une sur une
guerre alors est ce que c'est la partie
des gens enfin la résistance finalement
qui essayer d'abattre ce qu'ils ont vu
filer gens ou est-ce que ça n'a rien à
voir je sais pas ce qu'il faut faire
je pense que je vais devoir me voir je
prends de ce délire là hop ça va
exploser
et là je fonce tf du temps non s'il y en
a un deuxième c'est sûr ça c'est fait il
faut juste pas que ce soit trop dégagé
par l'impact ok là j'y vais j'y vais j'y
vais j'y vais logiquement là ça passe ça
passe très très bien
on a serré les fesses mais on est bon
qu'est ce que c'est que cet endroit est
là faut que j'atteigne levier un battant
c'est chaud comme des les ondes de choc
qui me dégage je crois levier ce qui se
passe aussi une protection à temps merde
atteint ok j'ai compris je compris ok ça
a pété l'âge la baisse et je vais
derrière l'autre on est bon [ __ ] c'est
satan beaucoup fois retracer la ok on
trace c'est parti
ça passe on est bon j'espère qu'on va
voir ce que c'est que ce délire là qui
envoie les tirs pourquoi on verra bien
prenons l'échelle allons voir ce qui se
cache là haut
ah merde oui ça marche 6 sur l'échelle
oui oui attend ça c'est quoi ah ok c'est
pour l'arrêter voilà ok comme ça ça me
protège
allez on y va ici je suis protégé et là
on peut y aller a les fonds france
croissance
ok mais bon ça a pété va y aller faut y
aller faut y aller faut y aller
j'aurais jamais est un mec c'est cargo
ça veut dire quoi qu'il faut monter en
étant synchro penser c'est impossible
d'un sabot coup trop vite
à moins que non je pense que c'est ça le
piège justement ce faux pas l'activer il
faut monter en étant sacré opus toi
dépêche-toi c'était limite
ok du coup on va devoir se servir de ça
pour nous protéger là bas allez c'est
parti à l'écho
oui c'est passé oh mon dieu [ __ ] la
fasch alors ça c'est quoi ce truc qui
s'envole ouais il faut juste l'activer
ok on va attendre le temps que l'on de
choc passe et là on y va oui c'est parti
ok on est passés [ __ ] quel excellent
début d'épisode alors qu'ici ça fait ça
fait avancer la porte ou là il ya du
monde là je me cache derrière la porte
ce cas ok je peux la prendre et avancer
avec
mais ils vont tous mourir sous les
explosions non qu'est-ce qu'ils font qui
sont des cas ce qu'on dirait qu'il
semble pas les explosions bon bah les
mecs
moi je me tire avec ma portière ça vous
dérange pas si c'est les défenses mépris
des explosions ça n'arrive pas oh c'est
violent de ouf enfin je pense qu'il faut
utiliser l'élan auquel ce parti là on
avait de l'élan logiquement ça devrait
passer
oui [ __ ] splendide holla holla qui
sait que ça on pas sûr du robot on est
bien alors là attention parce que la
poule à
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire là il faut
juste que je saute ok ok ce parti
je me cache derrière ça ok on s'est
cachés on peut continuer c'est trop bien
fait mais qu à tiens au nom mais pas
pendant que je stagne il devrait y avoir
une règle 10 ans vous avez pas le droit
légal là on a esquivé allaité mes choix
des végétaux dépêche-toi dépêche toi tu
vas mourir dépêche toi c'est bon on est
sauvé on est sauvé on est bon on peut y
aller fois c'était intense est parti là
mais tu exploses quoi vraiment n'implose
comme une merde là y'a plus ou non ses
moi y'a plus on peut y aller mais
totalement automatisé a alors on ouvre
sa way et on s'en va vers le bas ouais
comme ça on sent pas les ondes de choc
qui nous tue ou lente et sans vraiment
très profond pourquoi je vous dis ça
passe
oh oh oh
alors
on est vraiment très profond voilà
j'étais en train de vous dire pourquoi
je vous dis ça parce qu'on n'a pas envie
de retourner dans l'eau et de se
retrouver avec les les vipères ou [ __ ]
mais un faucon s'échappe là on est en
train de se noyer
ok on y va on y va on y va on est en vie
en ait envie à les arrêter
on y est c'est bon et vivant c'est bon
ça passe wow c'était limite [ __ ] au
moins on est loin des yeux grudge sous
marins on peut s'en sortir alors on va
devoir choper la corde à gauche par ci
un petit levier
[ __ ] c'était intense mais que ses
débuts de vidéos ça va stresser du cul
c'est parti
au plus on est mort quoi
hop là c'est passé [ __ ] c'était limite
alors où on arrive
moi je veux juste éviter les tout ce qui
est de grandes choses marin et tout ce
qui est les robots qui te choque par la
jambe ou le bras après les chiens
franchement on s'était habitué à bas
prix un petit peu les contrer ok alors
là il ya un truc à faire c'est sûr avec
les deux ok on active ça y'en a à gauche
a bien servi à quelque chose
on le saura plus tard bah voilà ouais
moi j'ai pas tout compris on va bien
voir
je vous en parlais je vous en parlais à
c'est tellement glauque que ça et le
bouton ça allonge en danse à la salle al
avance de hockey mais à quoi nous avance
cette plateforme à je sais j'ai compris
ok c'est pour aller encore plus haut ok
mais ça passe au dessus
clac et là elle est bloqué on va pouvoir
aller encore plus revoilà très bien on
est bon on est bon on se dirige quand
même vers ce grand âge elle est en
dessous nous mais non mais non juillet
lyon de vichy elle me stresse
non mais ça va il est attaché il est pas
bien lui c'est pas de ganges en bonne
santé ça oh j'ai rien dis oh le bâtard
ouais bah ouais bah fais toi plaisir
mais toi bien ouais je crois qu'il faut
aller attendez j'ai cru voir un anneau
ou à les attendre et on va voir la
regarder ça a c'est une corde s'était
fait voler alors tu étais ou pas on va
un [ __ ] attendent
on va essayer d'aller le plus loin
possible mec c'est sûr si tu vas plus
loin tu vas pas le plus loin loin loin
possible en bike shop
allez on y va ok c'est parti il va
arriver tellement vite regardez le il à
l'affût avec ses cheveux longs [ __ ] tu
arrêtes tu nous laisse en paix [ __ ]
okei okei on continue notre route
on est bien on est bien parti pour
s'offrir finale mais ça soit en fait ils
essaient juste de rejoindre justement la
résistance ce garçon en fait je en train
de me dire c'est peut-être ça le truc
allez c'est parti
comme ça on a le temps de passer et de
fermer la part d'arnaud non si on donne
c'est sûr qu'on peut l'affirmer c'est
sur un mon avis il ya un rebord vous
faut aller la salle à c'est là qu'il
faut aller leur bord c'est ça oui [ __ ]
génial et il est en ben j'en ai marre du
de grudd j'en ai marre je vais pas vous
mentir tu arrêtes de mothern the grudge
1 a marre de toi
[ __ ] allez on y va il me manque les
les esclaves là qu'on contrôle avec le
casque 1
c'est un peu glauque mais c'est vrai je
pense qu'il va falloir commencer à se
balancer à quoi ça sert qu'est-ce qu'on
est censé faire avec ça tintin est
accroché au bout ah j'ai compris gco ok
j'ai compris hors cat en fait faut aller
de l'autre côté aller dans l'eau comme
ça elle vient et ensuite on revient ici
via le crochet est comme ça elle reste
loin de nous et ouais ouais où il est au
plus bas le crochet ici voyons ce tram
juste les pieds vient elle a du coup il
est un peu plus loin et ça va nous
laisser le temps de pouvoir passer donc
et on est bien c'est parti t'as intérêt
à dépêcher mon pote
le timing est très serré ok j'ai appuyé
à sa ferme ça on passe elle passe pas
yes une the grudge des fonds marins en
moins on est passés alors j'espère juste
que ce n'est pas le retour de l'ombre de
choc
1 on est prêt à fêter sa forêt à mike ça
s'annonce tellement mal on est parti non
c'est bon ça parce que c'est que cette
porte
on peut la pousser à bon on va la
pousser tout de suite
sans perdre de temps ok oh non non mais
prévenez quand il se passe des choses
comme ça ah merde c'était là j'ai fait
de la merde je suis le cac a été bon
c'est juste la regarde et hop on est
sauvé on est bien on va la retrouver de
l'autre côté on va pas se mentir le
flanc fans grande distance la vue la
marche qu'on atteint aux îles bouton ah
oui le bouton oui il ya un peu de
l'autre côté pour la fermer ou pas ou on
meurt mais ça sera possible ah ok j'ai
compris
on la tire ici sur le bouton on ouvre la
porte on se barre rapidement la
préférence au [ __ ] [ __ ] de merde
désolé mais le pito ça fout la pression
on la tire
de l'autre côté comme ça on aura le
temps ensuite de passer par la porte
bien et du coup on peut repasser par la
trappe et atteindre l'autre est fermé la
porte même [ __ ] j'suis con ok cette
fois on a réussi [ __ ] on est bien le
monstre sous marin est enfermé derrière
une porte en acier trempé tremper dans
l'eau en plus du coup pure et la bonne
blague qui de thor atmosphère on retombe
sur une chaîne ok
on a autant mais seul but c'est ce qui
vient de se fasse et je peux m'en sortir
là en fait je peux jouer à pourquoi ça
joue elle devrait avoir tué laisse moi
[ __ ] mais il nous amène jusqu où là on
n'est pas censé être là dans le doute
ok on va être ressuscitée
attends je suis surpris là elle nous a
branché pourrais tu nous as branche est
d'accord inga c'est partir en couille là
ok et là on part en monde de dori et les
poissons vous nous escorter jusqu'à la
surface le monde de inside ou part sur
un remix
alors où la caisse qui a du coup tout en
bas d'accord une sorte de portail
ok ils sont pas en train de manger là
quand même les poissons hein
vous êtes juste en train de m'aider
c'est ça
quoi on a envie
quoi mais non on devrais être mort
depuis dix années je remonte ça sert à
rien on aimait du kunar espace limité
maintenant écouter on va pas s'en
plaindre mon gars assez des vitres non
non c'est pas des vitres juste un
bâtiment abandonné sous l'eau
ok mais écoutez on avance avec mes potos
les poissons le monde de side hall à
l'arrière des ders la vitre au fond en
voilà des créatures
c'est tête le truc qu'elle nous a
branché qui nous a greffé des bronchites
fait je n'ai permettre de respirer
donc ce grade je voulais pas me tuer en
fait elle voulait juste nous donner des
bronchites et nous permettent de vivre
sous l'eau que tous les humains aimerait
pouvoir vivre un jour finalement pas sur
quoi on va tomber on va pas tomber sur
une sorte de poulpes géants de la mort
mécanique ou je sais pas quoi non
regardez ça c'est quoi
faucheux rentrer là dedans ça se referme
ok c'est bon on est passés qu'est ce que
c'est que cet endroit voilà ça ça va
tourner ça ça ça va nous tuer elle en
passe vite fait un an que ça tourne ok
on est
et qu'est-ce qu'on prend cher dans cet
épisode qui est dit là bas on va
attendre
mais ça va nous sortir à j'aurais dû
m'accrocher un truc je pense j'aurais dû
m'accrocher un truc ça regarde et voilà
je vais m'accrocher là on est accroché
on est bien on craint rien craint rien
ok on y va faut passer le deuxième aussi
non et on peut s'accrocher donc non
légaux oh [ __ ] mais pièce est chaud je
perds mes chevilles mais qui début je
tenais je tenais je tenais je dois
dépêche toi oh oh c'était limite
non non on a
en fait je crois que ça avait ouvert une
trappe
j'aurais dû passer par la trappe alors
qu'est ce qu'il y avait voilà c'est ça
fallait à passer de l'eau ou encore
d'accord c'est vrai qu'on peut respirer
sous l'eau j'avais oublié ses six commun
ok on y est purée un petit cadavre et
rythmé mon pote
toi t'as pas eu le grunge qui t'a
branché qui t'a permis de respirer sous
l'eau
allez en avance ok ah non
oui bah oui faut reprendre vos réflexes
hop là c'est parti
ouais mais non on voit maintenant ouais
mais non ça lui en fait on a beaucoup
plus de temps quand le col allumé à
l'autre côté donc on va attendre et là
on va y aller c'est parti go go go go go
à ça va changer long [ __ ] c'est malin
non c'est ça ça me permet d'avancer plus
à l'est allez on termine on termine
jackson oui là on est bien allé à plus
la lumière on s'appelle ça c'est fait
qu'est la faut sauter bien dans le trou
allez on vise le trou oui pas de grunge
non mais en fait elle nous fait même
plus pas parce qu'en fait il nous a
sauvés ou par contre voir rien la
hollande audi dont mais je suis con ok
en fait faut juste immédiatement
ressortir donc d'aller voir ce qu'il ya
dans le fond marin et là c'est quoi le
délire
ok ok ou là c'est quoi ces des capsules
ça c'est des trucs dans lesquels on
frise les gens ok endroits glauques
endroit extrêmement au revoir on appuie
sur ce bouton
pourquoi fermer le haut d'avoir une
raison à tout ça les invités je reviens
en arrière qu'est-ce qu'il ya de l'eau
ok je vais pouvoir ouvrir et ça va
qu'est ce que ça fait si j'ouvre ça lova
ce vide et c'est ça non ça fait juste un
passage pour pouvoir revenir quand je
vais faire une certaine chose ok c'est
bizarre là parce que je suis saoul
mais y'a plus de gravité c'est la vérité
comme inversé c'est bizarre non
je suis perdu à mon avis ici on ferme là
oh ouais et donc aucune idée on va
avancer on va voir de les voir un truc
plus loin qui va nous indiquer pourquoi
on a fermé cette fameuse trappe real est
deuxième bouton déjà ok qu'est ce qu'il
ya à faire là je comprends pas a
peut-être juste tout est ok là quand je
compris à voilà c'est bien ce qui me
semblait c'est parfaitement ce qui me
semblait ok je pense qu'on va devoir
leur amener là bas pour accéder à l'un
des fils là qui pendaient de de la mer
chez ce très bizarre là ça devrait le
faire avec c'est un peu penché est-ce
qu'on va être dessus au mode skateboard
aller au longboard c'est parti est-ce
que ça passe oui merde on est trop long
du coup ça nous apprendre à nous prendre
pour des mecs du futur garde il va
arriver attention c'est parti
allez c'est beau à et ben voilà la
trappe à quoi doit servir à maintenant
maintenant ok j'ai compris il faut
l'activer au moment où il passe on ferme
le plafond c'est ça oui c'est beau ça du
coup on retourne de l'autre côté
et là je pense qu'on va faire un truc
entre suis là et l'autre attendez on
peut le mettre cela à bord mais sinon on
les empile tout simplement
ok faut faire ça voilà on va faire un
double ça va chier mon pote au plat et
du coup là on est dans la mer ok aidé à
caen la mer était inversée au bugue mec
c'est quoi ça oh ok ok bah écoute et ce
quoi faire c'est extrêmement simple que
ça fait déjà presque une heure quinze
jours est bon sur ce thème et pour le
dernière épisode d'inside hélas
apparence est effrayant c'est jean pendu
dans le sens inverse par le crâne qu'est
ce qui se passe dans une salle bondée
steppa meadows ça vous a plu pour
centrer pour le prochain épisode
j'espère que ce let's play ambiance
tamisée ambiance posée vous paie
toujours portez vous bien à très vite
sur thoune be